welcome to this video Moscow plush I
cannot pronounce that we have a an even
score two wins two losses fraud Ross
that's pretty hydro rate yeah but
probably do too I know stalemate and
what not no quick choice or anything
okay he's playing them I'm the snake Ben
Oni with bishop to d6 funny line that is
some hmm yeah maybe slightly dodgy but
it's not terribly bad so it's not that I
have a simple refutation or anything
available what i'm doing here is just
just developing mostly it's called snake
benoni because of this snake like
maneuver Bishop d6c seven possibly to a
five like this Sidewinder type crawl or
how do you crawl is probably am wrong
word but I think you get the idea okay
um I want to at the end play efore and
f4 so getting the King out of this and
prepare a form so you for this is on why
not efore 4f 45
b5 I have fun under control okay so a
five now IM to keep b5 a little bit a
little bit at bay at least it isn't
clear if i had to play king edge one but
so somewhat typical lazy blitz move
where you say okay let's prepare it so
that nothing bad is happening but it's
really not a necessary move here okay f4
yeah that was the idea all along nah
playing this now would be really strange
hmm okay i can go nite c4 i am simply
too why not you can go Bishop b5 I know
but I wonder how I problematic that
really is I mean this looks like a very
active position that i have with any
every five anytime I can also take I can
take them and then take be five there's
also actually quite good yeah if we look
at this pawn takes Knight a three and I
well be four 94 is fantastic and well
now Bishop a five-night b5 as if you
also should be quite good for possible
f5 later I mean I got the bishop pair in
addition to the center and if you give
one side the bishop pair and the center
let's means quite a lot usually and it's
nice as somewhat somewhat off yeah I
don't know maybe you should take a fiver
I mean other moves look it don't look
any better yeah maybe Knight f6 now
something like that but this probably
runs into I mean even f5 as an option
and 96cm he is somewhat another he has
to to keep the a5 Bishop also protected
him
it's a very very problematic pollution
okay I hear this save him but if five
young I definitely want to play that
well I'm even fire head of the clock but
this seven this was such a natural cause
of events that i didn't even spend much
time on it so yeah guess sending the
green to the side of the board cannot be
bad or to the edge of the board the
corner yeah after the six is almost
stalemated him night cannot move on I g6
cannot move and my plan is just Queen d5
Bishop c4 and resigns I'm okay d 7 is
also quite nice might be going to go
into win win this night or after 97 I
can take and play e-cigs which really
should win if not something is seriously
wrong here so Bishop c4 may be on can
also just take f7 of course yeah maybe
rook f7 check and Bishop c7 was my idea
to force promotion maybe m-maybe I have
something even more more decisive yeah
this is actually check checkmate
territory already
king of eight Bishop Disick's check 97
queen of three mate or queen of one mate
yeah the snake be known as a somewhat
dodgy opening it is some why not resign
not like completely incorrect but it is
really risky and we have seen an example
why yeah I don't know this I don't know
when it started to go downhill the King
move is a bit lazy but probably not bad
and I went here and well this is the
center and I don't really know what he
has what about what is so what is it
that he can do against me just pushing
ahead efore f4 and stuff can I went a
five look yeah I thought you would
probably play look he ate or something I
mean it must be better with the center
and he does not really have any great
some direct counter play but after that
yeah all this probably does not help gee
I just took well the computer wants to
play f5 okay now it switches to night 83
yeah this is some in a cases or cases of
what else yeah you can just simply play
the the symbol play the simple moves and
they win you txt x6 here rook chicks
yeah he has really no check check no way
forward I mean this is Jack a cute way
to checkmate and yeah there is there is
nothing that you can do again step
forward we're just the maid here exactly
I hear this is also made Queen Queen a
fire or what is the computer giving this
is I wouldn't have found of course
check check me it's all so cute yeah I
don't know this was an opening going
wrong really really badly okay but a
nice game I liked it thanks for watching